[Music]
i love your accent i know that
where you come from this is quite common
but uh
i immediately
i just uh i just love that accent i
think it's so fantastic
i love your accent too
jolly good
you've lived in both the united states
and the united kingdom you've you've
you've gone back and forth
uh you mentioned your single you've
dated both
british men american men preference do
you like what's the difference really
um i think that american men
are a little more confident as we just
saw um
and maybe maybe they'll be like you know
hey you want to go out with me and then
in england
i think it's a bit more like the girls
have to say
excuse me would you like to go out with
me and i think that movie is the
difference
really so uh richmond they're shy are
they shy
or is it that it's propriety they want
to not be too rude
exactly that you know they're raised
with um maybe uh
a decorum and um uh
but it's not good in in dating it's nice
to have a confidence you want a mandate
this is what uh
you want a man to take charge that's
what women have always told me over the
years you want a man to take
charge and i was in high school i wasn't
like that i was like
oh you know you were always quite
tall which did a bit of work at least
you'd be noticed
i would be noticed but it wasn't good i
grew very quickly
i grew like three feet in a year and uh
i
couldn't catch up the weight wouldn't
catch up for a long time you were very
thin
i was not just thin i was like a circus
act
did you get bullied bullied did i get
bullied yeah
yes yes i did get bullied um
what was that my parents uh were cool
i'm sorry other children were very kind
okay okay
my parents were like look at him he's a
freak
[Applause]
i i i i have to ask you about the uh
you've been had experience learning uh
when you lived in this country did your
accent start to go away i was curious
about that yeah because i lived here
when i was uh very young
and um from the ages of 9 to 12 or 13
and i spoke like this and there is a
slight i mean that
we are kind of divided by a common
language because apart from the fact
that we spell words differently we also
pronounce words differently
um and i was sort of being misunderstood
and so my contemporaries at school or
the other kids they uh they asked me to
speak like them
and i did so you learn to actually speak
with an american accent
yeah just because as a kid it's easier
to sort of be part of the group than it
is to stand outside it
i think that changes as you get older
but when i was younger i felt it was
easier to
um to just be part of the group and it
was a fun group
so where was this what area of the
united states was this in los angeles oh
so you were speaking with a los angeles
accent for a while
yeah so what kind of what stuff were you
doing can you give me an
idea of just was your whole just like
you just talk like that instead of
talking like
me that's weird that you can just
you can just change like that wow that's
like peer pressure as a child that'll do
that to you
that's pretty amazing
everyone in the audience is like she's
one of us
i like her a lot
it did involve saying like about ten
times in each sentence
it's a helpful word um like yeah it is
it's sort of especially in california
but realizes the comma
yeah when you have nothing to say kids
have people out here just say like like
you know like like i think it's where
you know comma like when i went to
the bathroom like comma
right wait
let's do that again in america and then
maybe you'll be on my side okay you know
like when i went to the bathroom like
am i one of you this is every other
interview i do on this show
you have to explain that to me